في اماكن الفوضى كيف يمكن لكم ان تقوموا
بالتنميه يعني لن يكون سهل على الاطلاق
الوصول الى مرحله التنميه في مناطق توتر
اصلا
اعوذج
دعيني يشرح الامر كيف يمكن للناس النجاه
من الفوضى ليس بمقدور اي منه من يذهب الى
المدينه وان يقف في طابور الانتظار لتلقي
مساعده غذائيه عليهم ان يرعوا امورهم
الخاصه واولادهم سواء كان ذلك في
افغانستان اين عثرنا في خضم الازمه
السياسيه العاصفه على نساء نشانا مزارعهن
الخاصه ومشاريعنا صغيره بتمويلات بسيطه
وكل منهن ترعى بين سته وسبعه اشخاص ذلك
يسمح على المدى الطويل بانشاء شبكه
اقتصاديه على الصعيد الوطني تسمح للاشخاص
بان يتعايشوا مع الازمات ويخرج منها في
اطار يحافظ على كرامتهم حيث ينبغي مساعده
الناس على تجاوز الازمات فانهم سيستسلمون
ما يزيد من تعميق الازمه ويؤثرون على
الدول الاخرى فيصبحون لاجئين او نازحين
داخل دولهم او على حدودها وقد جربنا ذلك
افضل مثال على ذلك اللاجئون الصوماليون
الذين يعيشون في كينيا في مخيمات ولدت
فيها جده وامهات وبنات ما يعني ان ثلاثه
اجيال وقعنا في شراك هذا الموقف انه نزاع
مثير للاسف جدا ومدان بشده ولكن هذا هو
الواقع وهو ما ينبغي ان نذكر به الناس
دوما هذه هي الحقيقه وهي ما ينبغي ان نركز
عليه